existe un problema grave en nuestro país
grave nuestra ciudad en nuestro estado
que la pobreza
es un problema triste es real es grave
y hay una fórmula muy interesante para
poder entender comprender un poquito el
porqué la pobreza
la pobreza está ligada con la falta de
ingresos económicos es una lógica muy
sencilla no hay dinero no tengo ingresos
pues hay pobreza
pero porque no hay ingresos no hay
ingresos porque no hay empleo
a través del empleo en donde ganas
dinero
y no eres pobre
pero entonces porque no hay empleo
no hay empleo entonces porque no hay
empresas no hay empresas que generen los
empleos donde puedo ganar dinero y no
ser pobre
pero la pregunta tal vez más compleja
sería entonces porque no hay empresas y
no hay empresas porque no hay
condiciones
de competir no hay condiciones que nos
permitan emprender para generar los
espacios que son el empleo que le
permita a la gente ingresos económicos y
no ser pobre
los únicos generadores de empleos
sostenibles los únicos capaces de
desarrollar a las personas es la
iniciativa privada
son los empresarios
son los emprendedores entonces cómo le
hago para despertar el espíritu
emprendedor en casa ese es el reto
a través de experiencias vividas en mi
familia con mis amigos con mi entorno me
he dado cuenta que la única respuesta
para esto es fomentando hábitos
pero cuáles altos hay muchos
6 son los que te voy a compartir primero
la puntualidad después la honestidad
después la tolerancia el liderazgo el
trabajo en equipo y por último y no por
eso menos importante el servicio a los
demás empiezo con la puntualidad en
méjico 28.5 por ciento de las personas
se considera puntual
pero el 67% es decir dos de cada tres
mexicanos se consideran impuntuales
datos reales
el 65 de los empleados llegan tarde o
después de la hora acordada a una
reunión pero sólo en lo grave 60% de los
jefes o los supervisores también llegan
tarde a las reuniones
los problemas de la puntualidad es un
problema grave es un problema serio en
nuestra sociedad
el reto de esta charla sería compartir
algunas ideas algunas sugerencias para
en casa fomentar el espíritu emprendedor
a través de esos hábitos y como promuevo
la puntualidad en casa te comparto 5
ideas
la primera es enseñarles a no ignorar
las alarmas las alarmas no solo un
sonido más de la casa no es un sonido de
fondo de ambientación la alarma está por
algo no hay que ignorar las alarmas
respetar las alarmas y de preferencia
tener una no muchas una 2
recuérdales a tus hijos constantemente
que no pierdan el tiempo hijo a lo mejor
esto va a parecer la clásica de papá
deja de perder el tiempo pero hay que
insistir seguir insistiendo y seguir
insistiendo número tres la regla de los
15 minutos pero no de que tienes chance
de llegar 15 minutos más tarde sino que
necesitas estar listo 15 minutos antes
regla de oro la de los 15 minutos
4 crea un ambiente puntual en casa ahora
para levantarse ahora para ir a bañarse
hola para comer
hola para hacer los quehaceres del hogar
y por último recompensar la publicidad
se vale premiar se vale recompensar se
vale reconocer sobre todo si son niños
chiquitos el segundo valor es la
honestidad y permítanme compartirte un
texto que va a aparecer en tu pantalla y
dice lo siguiente la honestidad es muy
sencillo el concepto es la cualidad de
la persona honesta es decir es un
conjunto de atributos personales como la
fíjense decencia pudor dignidad
sinceridad justicia rectitud honradez en
el ser y en el actuar algo por conceptos
un poquito que parecieran anticuados
pero ojo lo que se signifique antiguo no
significa que sea anticuado son dos
cosas distintas lo anticuado pierde el
valor lo antiguo al contrario lo antigua
quiere valor con el tiempo no tal vez
con la finta
hay un estudio muy interesante que
también te estoy compartiendo en la
pantalla es un estudio que se hizo en
cerca de 40 países donde se tiraron a la
calle miles y miles y miles de carteras
con dinero y se me dio el tiempo de
respuesta a la capacidad de respuesta
con la cartera llena o con la cartera
vacía
méxico- de toda la muestra creo que nada
más lo compara otro país por ahí nada
más está en el último lugar en donde
llega la cartera pero lleva la cartera
vacía será hay un problema pues con el
concepto de honestidad en nuestro país
que está medido y hay que trabajar pero
como lo como como en casa como le puedo
hacer cinco ideas también interesantes
para este uno recompensar aquí
recompensar no no hay problema con
recompensar sobre todo repito si son
niños chicos recompensar la honestidad 2
hablar con la verdad y siempre encontrar
algo positivo en las personas
número 3 promover que se diga la verdad
aunque sea dura y la verdad es que
estamos viviendo tiempos muy complejos
en donde las emociones al parecer son
más importantes que las razones si
enseñamos en casa a nuestros hijos a
hablar con la verdad aunque ésta sea
dura creo que estaremos haciéndole un
enorme favor al futuro de ellos y al
futuro de este mundo número 4 motivarlos
a buscar amigos honestos en eso si
podemos los papás intervenir un poco tal
vez no cuando los hijos están más
grandes pero cuando están creciendo
podemos hacer podemos influir y por
último cumple tus promesas es decir no
puede ser un ejemplo de deshonestidad si
no estás cumpliendo tus promesas
incluyendo los castigos en casa
la ponencia es un tercer valor que
quiero convertir que es el
consentimiento dicen es el
consentimiento no solo de un bien menor
para evitar un mal sino a veces conceder
un mal menor para evitar una mayor
también es raro no va de nuevo que es la
tolerancia es el consentimiento no sólo
de un bien menor para evitar un mal
sino a veces conceder un mal menor para
evitar uno mayor
pero ojo mucho cuidado con esto mucho
cuidado porque la tolerancia no es
permitir la mentira por flojera a
debatir oa pensar muchas veces porque no
queremos debatir porque no queremos
pensar un poco permitimos a la mentira y
es un error también
número 3 ojo conceder al abuso por ser
políticamente correcto
de ser políticamente correcto no es un
pretexto para dejar que las cosas
sucedan
y número 3 ojo con defender un error por
ser empático por querer quedar bien cedo
y defiendo inclusive un error o algo que
sé que está mal es tolerancia por ver
una verdadera tolerancia
y como promueve la tolerancia en casa 5
tips para que los apuntes primero
fortaleza espiritual al margen de su
credo y tu religión
fortaleza espiritual 2 competir y buscar
la enseñanza en el triunfo para salir en
el fracaso
competir
y disfrutar el triunfo pero también el
fracaso 3 insistir en la importancia de
la complementariedad
donde no nada más competimos porque hay
escenarios en donde competimos pero la
inmensa mayoría de los escenarios en la
vida real es de complementariedad
hombres y mujeres complemento no
competencia complemento cada uno con sus
cualidades cada uno con sus
características con sus virtudes y con
sus errores
otro tip para promover la tolerancia en
casa es practicar el deporte oa la
actividad cultural en equipo en equipo
es la clave en equipo y número 5
reflexionar y sobre todo reprimir de
inmediato el bullying no permitirlo a
ninguna cosa
el liderazgo es tan importante que la
falta de auténticos líderes es igual o
peor que una guerra nuclear o una
catástrofe nuclear o una epidemia como
la que estamos viviendo ha sido peor el
liderazgo del manejo de una crisis como
la que estamos teniendo hoy
en la última encuesta que hizo mitovsky
respecto
las instituciones a las que los
mexicanos confiamos los resultados son
sorprendentes y bien interesantes las
tres primeras instituciones a las que el
mexicano sino decir admirar reconoce su
liderazgo son las escuelas o las
universidades la iglesia católica y el
ejército son las tres instituciones en
las que el mexicano reconoce y confía
pero lo curioso son las que están hasta
el fondo y déjenme platicarles un
poquito de ellas son la policía los
sindicatos los senadores el presidente
los diputados y los partidos políticos
es decir los que nos representan son las
peores instituciones a los ojos de los
mexicanos algo está mal en esta fórmula
o en esta pirámide de la confianza de la
honestidad y el liderazgo
como promuevo el liderazgo en casa 5
tips 1 motivarnos a toda oportunidad
para participar o expresarse en público
2 fomentar los trabajos en equipo y yo
insisto deporte en equipo
todo el deporte es bueno pero es mejor
si es en equipo número 3 promover el
trabajo desde pequeños con pequeñas
acciones y si con recompensa
4 animarlos a la lectura mucha lectura a
escuchar música buena música número 5
todo a su tiempo
tampoco los empujes a una etapa que
todavía no les corresponde estamos
hablando del liderazgo
el siguiente con la siguiente
habilidades de trabajo en equipo y el
trabajo en equipo porque es importante
que insistía el deporte el deporte en
equipo déjame decirte por qué porque nos
complementamos en el deporte cada quien
juega un rol piensa en el que tú quieras
en el béisbol en el básquet en el fútbol
americano cada quien tiene un rol nos
complementamos reconocemos en donde yo
no puedo y el otro sí puede dos porque
terminamos más pronto si hacemos las
cosas en equipo terminamos los trabajos
más pronto y terminamos las tareas más
pronto número tres porque aprendemos a
confiar ya que confíen en nosotros y yo
pasar la bola y que me la pasen a mí a
dejarte a ti tal lectura y que tú me
dejes a mí reflexionar la siguiente
lectura porque somos más creativos
cuando estamos varios pensamos de
diferente forma más ideas y logramos
mejores objetivos y por último porque es
mucho más divertido que estar solo
hasta por conveniencia es más divertido
trabajar en equipo como promueve el
trabajo en equipo en casa te comparto
5 tips para promoverlo uno descubre tus
talentos y motivarlos el de tus hijos a
coordinar los dos dales
responsabilidades que estén conectadas
con toda la familia no trabajo
individual actividades que estén
conectadas con papá con mamá con los
abuelos con los tíos oclusivos los
vecinos con los hermanos 3 fomenta el
sentido de pertenencia y protección a la
familia primero es la familia el equipo
más importante es la familia chicos
grandes gordos pelones altos morenos
como quieras pero lo más importante es
la familia es el primer equipo y
promover el espíritu de equipo de
familia es clave para el trabajo en
equipo en el futuro dejar helio y
convertirlo en el nosotros y por último
celebrar juntos las alegrías
también perdón pasar juntos las
tristezas
y el siguiente la siguiente habilidad es
el la participación y el servicio a los
demás y la gráfica que te muestro en
pantalla es triste esos son los
porcentajes si no los voy a explicar a
detalle pero son los porcentajes de
participación de los ciudadanos te voy a
dar un tipo así muy muy sencillo por
ejemplo en las asociaciones
profesionales que son las cámaras los
colegios de arquitectos de abogados de
médicos en méxico solamente el 5.4 de
los profesionistas participan en eeuu
más del 12 por ciento actividades como
por ejemplo las asociaciones religiosas
en méxico de manera activa participa más
o menos el 12 por ciento en una
actividad religiosa en eeuu cerca del 40
por ciento en brasil el 50 por ciento de
la población hay un problema de
participación y de servicio a los demás
no participamos necesitamos participar
más servir más porque hay mucha
necesidad fuera pero como promuevo el
servicio a los demás
2 tips 1 hay que mostrar a nuestros
hijos el rezago y explicarles los
motivos explicarle los problemas si hay
que abordar los problemas los rezagos la
pobreza en nuestro país y explicárselo y
número 2 buscar en una causa altruista y
comprometernos con ella la verdad es que
hay muchísimas causas solamente hay que
elegir una y comprometerse con ella
yo te quiero que dejar solo con una
reflexión para el tema de emprendimiento
lo importante por supuesto es que el
joven o el niño sea feliz
y si decides ser emprendedor pues que lo
sea
pero que lo sea haciendo lo que le gusta
pero con conciencia con responsabilidad
con los ojos puestos en el cielo pero
con los pies bien puestos en la tierra
gracias